usines à l'arrêt paralysie du commerce
chute du trafic aérien et du tourisme
alors que l'épidémie due coronavirus n'a
pas encore atteint son pic
l'inquiétude grandit sur son impact
économique surtout en chine où le virus
fait des ravages
alors dans quelle mesure ce coronavirus
peut-il contaminer le reste de
l'économie mondiale porte-t-il les
germes d'une récession on voit cela tout
de suite avec l'économiste jacques sapir
bienvenue jacques
merci olivier alors jacques faut-il
s'inquiéter des conséquences économiques
qui est de cette épidémie
eh bien oui parce que les différentes
informations que l'on a ne sont pas
effectivement réjouissante alors il faut
savoir que cette épidémie d'une
coronavirus elle va avoir des effets sur
l'économie mondiale et sur l'économie
chinoise en particulier à travers quatre
canaux le premier canal est celui de la
production
et c'est tout à fait normal la chine est
aujourd'hui le premier producteur
mondial et avec la chine il ya toute la
zone asie-pacifique l'accord et le
vietnam le japon
après il y à la question de la demande
évidemment quand on produit beaucoup on
consomme beaucoup de matières premières
et là aussi il risque d'y avoir des
perturbations importantes en particulier
sur les prix des matières premières une
3 un troisième canal qu'il faut aussi
regarder de près c'est la question du
transport aérien et du tourisme
et c'est particulièrement important en
france où on le sait les touristes
chinois qui ne sont pas très nombreux
mais kim et joue un rôle qui est
particulièrement important dans la
balance touristique française enfin le
quatrième canal c'est le canal bancaire
et on va voir aussi que la les
perturbations dans la production que ce
soit en demande où que ce soit en
production directe et bien vont avoir
des conséquences sur l'activité des
banques et des assurances alors avant
d'aller plus loin jacques je vous
propose de voir comment les français que
nous avons rencontré réagissent à ce
risque économique potentielle regarder
écouter tous les pays sont plus ou moins
touchés alors effectivement la chaîne et
plus
plus touchés parce que le virus est né
là bas mais je pense que le problème est
mondial la croissance mondiale et tiré
quand même par la croissance chinoise
donc on est tous concernés c'est c'est
l'interdépendance des économies que des
gens qui vont plus travailler qui sont
obligés de rester en quarantaine rester
chez eux
les entreprises peuvent pas fonctionner
j'ai des amis à pékin également qu'ils
sont quand on est chez eux qui va sortir
une fois par semaine pour faire des
courses
non non tout ça c'est dramatique pour
les galeries chinoises et voient qu'il
ya déjà des chaînes de production qui
sont arrêtés airbus a arrêté une épreuve
consommateurs de produits finis et plus
et puis sort un impact sur nous
évidemment pas déjà par rapport au
tourisme on a beaucoup de chinois qui
viennent nous visiter donc forcément
cela on les verra pas prendre un petit
moment ça va ça va marquer le pas un
petit peu pour l'hôtellerie et c'est
donc moi je pense que l'économie
française va souffrir un petit peu ça
dépendra de son impact petite récession
voire plus selon les l'impact sur la
société sûre on va dire l'économie
générale vous le voyez déjà maintenant
en bourse sa remontée déjà tout le monde
attend que ça s'arrête
aida chine elle va redémarrer beaucoup
plus fort encore on est dans une
économie où on s'est mis pieds poings
liés avec avec l'économie chinoise un
tant mieux pour les chinois alors votre
réaction jackass convient d'entendre
bien oui on voit très bien que les
personnes interrogées ont évoqué à peu
près tous les problèmes qui se posent de
la production au tourisme et tous sont
conscients que ces événements même s'ils
sont pour l'instant largement cantonnée
en chine et bien auront une implication
auront des conséquences sur l'économie
française alors regardons le premier
effet dont vous avez parlé les arrêts de
production sont-ils significatif
oui tout à fait et là il faut bien voir
que en fait on est face à deux problèmes
le premier problème évidemment que ce
sont les arrêts de production c'est
l'effet direct parce qu'il ya
aujourd'hui au delà de one plus de 23
provinces qui sont concernés et ses
effets directs ils touchent différents
secteurs l'électronique l'automobile
l'aéronautique la pharmacie alors pour
l'aéronautique en particulier on à
l'arrêt de la chaîne de produits
lyon 2 airbus en chine ce qui a un
impact sur les sous-traitants d'airbus
c'est le cas de safran et sur
l'électronique
c'est évidemment l'arrêt ou le quasi
arrêt des usines foxconn et puis après
on a les effets indirects
ce sont les effets sur les
sous-traitants il faut savoir que la
chine produit énormément de pièces pour
d'autres pays ce qu'on appelle les
chaînes de valeur est aujourd'hui en
particulier dans l'automobile
ça a un effet tout à fait dramatique
l'industrie coréenne est d'ores et déjà
à l'arrêt et il y a des conséquences
extrêmement importantes sur les
industries françaises italiennes et
allemandes
alors on peut-on estimer réellement cet
impact oui alors on sait que l'épidémie
du sras sahin 2002 2003 avaient provoqué
une chute de 0,5 point du pipe mondiale
le strass était bien plus meurtrier que
le coronavirus mais ils étaient bien
moins contagieux or aujourd'hui ce qui
pose problème c'est évidemment cette
contagion qui amène le gouvernement
chinois à isoler des régions entières et
a demandé aux gens de rester chez eux
alors ce que l'on estime aujourd'hui
c'est que le coronavirus pourrait avoir
un impact au minimum d'un point de pipe
dans le premier semestre
il y à des experts qui évoquent une
possibilité de deux points de pib en
moins pour le premier semestre
et du côté de la demande que va-t-il se
passer alors évidemment quand on produit
beaucoup ce qui est le cas la chine
on est un gros consommateur de matières
premières et la chute de la production
engendre la chute de la demande
on le voit sur la question des prix du
pétrole les prix du pétrole ont baissé
de pratiquement 20 % environ deux
semaines et demie trois semaines alors
ça une importance considérable pour les
producteurs en particulier les
producteurs américains
les petites sociétés américain qui
produisent essentiellement ce qu'on
appelle du pétrole de schiste qui se
retrouvent
avec des revenus très sévèrement
contracter ce qui est dit sur le pétrole
peut s'étendre à différents autres
matières premières qu'il s'agisse de
minerais ou qu'il s'agisse de matières
alimentaires alors jacques vous nous
avez montré l'impact de l'épidémie sur
la production et la demande dit y en at
il d'autres
bien sûr il y en a deux autres olivier
et en particulier sur la question du
transport aérien et du tourisme
alors il faut savoir qu'il y a l'année
dernière il y avait 2 4 millions de
visiteurs chinois sur 89 millions en
france vous voyez ça ne pèse pas très
lourd en nombre seulement comme ses
visiteurs chinois comme ces touristes
chinois ont un très fort pouvoir d'achat
ils consomment ils dépensent plus
exactement 1700 euros par visiteur alors
que la moyenne
elle est plutôt de l'ordre de 350 à 14
100 euros eh bien ça va avoir un effet
tout à fait important par exemple si le
nombre de visiteurs était divisé par
quatre ce qui est tout à fait possible
puisque aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
flux de visiteurs venant de chine sur la
france et bien si le nombre de visiteurs
était divisé par quatre dans l'année
cela se traduirait par une perte de 3
milliards d'euros pour le secteur du
tourisme
c'est considérable et s'est
considérablement plus par exemple que ce
qui avait coûté l'année dernière le
mouvement des gilets jaunes pour le
mouvement des chemises jaunes ont parlé
de quelques centaines de millions
d'euros 2 à 300 millions d'euros en coût
direct
là on est plutôt sur 3 milliards dont on
voit qu'il ya un poids qui est
considérable l'autre problème c'est
évident pour le transport aérien le
transport aérien souffre beaucoup de
cette crise et si vous voulez une
l'ensemble du transport aérien qu'ils
s'agissent des vols intérieurs des vols
vers la chine des vols venant de chine
vers les terres bien on voit que cette
cour est en train de s'effondrer
en fait on sait qu'aujourd'hui il y à
70% des vols aériens intérieurs qui ont
été arrêtés 56 % des vols à
l'international et le nombre de
compagnies qui cessent de desservir la
chine temporairement évidemment le
que dure cette épidémie ne cesse de
s'accroître donc là aussi il y aura des
conséquences extrêmement importante
alors jacques nous avait aussi parlé en
introduction d'un possible effet sur les
banques en quoi les activités bancaires
pourrait-elle être touché par le corona
virus oui effectivement olivier et il
faut savoir que il y aura en réalité
potentiellement 2 et faire le premier
effet est liée à la chute de la
production les entreprises s'endettent
ce qui est tout à fait normale en
particulier pour l'investissement mais
avec cette chute de la production
elles auront de grandes difficultés à
rembourser leur prêt tout simplement à
payer en fait les intérêts ce qui veut
dire que les banques auront moins de
recettes et puis d'un autre côté il y a
des grandes sociétés qui se sont assurés
en particulier depuis la crise du sras
qui se sont assurés contre le cas
d'épidémie c'est le cas de foxconn c'est
le cas d'airbus
donc cela veut dire que les assurances
qui sont maintenant intimement liés aux
banques seront amenés à devoir débourser
des sommes d'argent importantes
autrement dit le secteur de la banque et
l'assurance va être coincé entre d'une
partie une baisse de revenus liés à la
chute de la production et d'un autre
côté des dépenses supplémentaires qui
sont liées à l'indemnisation des usines
à l'arrêt mais cette épidémie est ce
qu'elle peut provoquer une récession
mondiale ou une récession en france
alors oui c'est une question que l'on
peut poser il faut tout d'abord préciser
que cela dépendra beaucoup de la durée
de cette épidémie aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas si on va connaître le pic de
l'épidémie
d'ici la fin du mois de février et si
après cette épidémie va décliner
relativement rapidement il faut
l'espérer d'ailleurs compte tenu en
particulier des mesures extrêmement
sévère qu'a pris le gouvernement chinois
mais il n'est pas exclu non plus que
cette épidémie dure trois mois quatre
mois cinq mois dans ce cas évidemment
l'impact sur l'économie mondiale sera
très important alors maintenant l'impact
sur l'économie française
il est potentiellement d'autant plus
fort que l'économie française va mal on
c'est que au dernier trimestre de 2010 9
le pibe a diminué de 0 1% alors ça
pouvait être simplement un accident mais
si on se retrouve au premier ou au
deuxième trimestre de 2020 avec une
situation internationale qui évidemment
détériorés par cette épidémie
avec aussi une baisse générale de la
production liée par le manque de deux
pièces de rechange
le manque si vous voulez de
sous-ensembles qui sont produits en
chine
eh bien oui on pourrait avoir une chute
importante de la production alors que la
croissance était estimé à 1,1 1,2 pour
cent à la fin de l'année dernière les
chiffres réels pourraient se situer
plutôt à 0 7%
c'est un mauvais résultat et il faut
ajouter que d'autres économies sont
aussi très vulnérables
l'allemagne bien entendu et l'italie
merci beaucoup jacques pour toutes ces
explications comme toujours très
instructive à très bientôt sur rt france
merci beaucoup olivier